hi guys I'm here in Prague with this
wonderful man
Anthony water my little doggy in the
back and a little dog in the background
I thought we would make a video speaking
about language early because this man I
don't know if any of you you know knows
Anthony Mulder he's like what's your
what's your YouTube channels anyway uh
well now you can just search my name
Anthony Doerr doing and it'll be on
YouTube or the old name is fluent to
check one check write any talks about
language groaning Jesus got wonderful
videos and you should definitely check
them out today we're going to talk about
something interesting I'm in Prague and
I thought might as well make a video
about language learning because we
talked about that as well as obviously
other things and we're going to talk
about speaking fluently what does it
mean to be fluent in a foreign language
so Anthony what does it mean to be
fluent in a foreign language you tell me
Luka yes yes first no what do I mean by
it yeah a lot of people think it means
sounding exactly like a native speaker
but to me it's more about the language
flowing in two senses the first one is
that it flows out of your mouth without
huge gaps and without stuttering and so
on but more importantly it's about
flowing in conversations between people
it's very easy to have a monologue but
to have a conversation backwards and
forwards backwards and forwards is what
real fluency is about to me right so you
think that people think you have to know
a lot of words to speaker yeah this is a
really big trap actually the idea that
you really need a massive for copyright
I often said I had to learn in one
language class loads of names of fishes
and plants but I will never ever use but
people in the same class as me couldn't
say anything
they couldn't even use a five-word
sentence and that's really struck me as
completely useless I believe you need to
be fluent you can gain fluency with a
very small vocabulary yeah this is a
very very wise man you have to listen to
him so so you're what you're saying is
that basically you might know a lot of
words but you can't string sentences
together and but there are people
actually who know look
not that many words few words who can
actually have conversations that really
possible can you can you give the people
to listen to us some advice on how to do
that because one thing is to talk about
it one thing is to actually do it so
what you speak on check right because we
are here in Prague once again use you
you can learn and check for what - yes
few years ago you paid me speaking can I
speak any Cheng do you think of course
there you go
remember around he was like you know
talking to the ladies with dog because
we've got this wonderful dog we're
chatting with the ladies yeah you tell
me what will happen because now used to
be checked so you know you're not contra
maybe you don't even remember how it was
to try to learn a little bit bits and
pieces we might be very well oh I was
taking a few language classes and I
noticed that many of the people had a
very big vocabulary but they really felt
that the words were trapped in them and
they couldn't come out so I thought
these classes are pretty useless there
must be something else going on there
must be a conversational ability there's
got nothing to do with having a massive
vocabulary so I looked at discovered
that the language that people were using
in conversations wasn't the same kind of
stuff that we would talked about in
class and you can learn to have a
conversation with a very limited
vocabulary and then once you've got that
speaking ability going as you add future
vocabulary then has some context that
some some framework to fit into other
words you're learning endless this
you'll never say anything now I've
noticed that a couple of very
well-respected polyglots say well I
don't do that I don't have conversations
till I but a massive vocabulary but the
more the important point here is that
they've already been through the process
of speaking you know the languages and I
think it's a skill that once you've got
over this fear of the over the hurdle
once you've got a general speaking
ability it transfers that skill with
other languages that the you don't have
to fear anymore you realize that you
will be able to speak but when you're
early in the language learning perhaps
it's your first language getting over
the hurdle you can do it very quickly
once you've got over it the fear goes
away or
but somebody might retort to you that
okay you can speak a little bit of
course you can put these words together
but what happens if you don't actually
understand what people say because it's
always communication is always by
direction if it's awesome and and that
you know even though I speak checked
well people I there are still things I
don't understand and I've noticed that
when you're a beginner if you say to
somebody I need trained where go they'll
realize you're not fantastic and they'll
use simple language themselves the
person you're speaking with this is the
important in a conversation they are
just there level to you and even at my
level you know speak check well when I'm
in a group of checks they adjust their
level cutting down on the slang cutting
down on the obscure cultural references
we naturally all want the conversation
to flow we don't want it to be painful
so both sides are trying so would your
advice actually for beginner some people
just started learning a language to have
conversations with language partners
instead of throwing them tell some
people on the street where the situation
is a little bit difficult they might not
understand like imagine that you and I
were having a conversation in Italian oh
you already know you speak a little bit
of Italian but I actually had
conversations in Japanese where I found
out that even if I didn't understand
words of stuff she my Japanese tutor she
was wonderful because for example what
she was saying everybody would
understand I do this I you know so
comprehensible input is also made with
gestures not only with can speak slowly
you can adjust the level but you have a
lot of like I can show can understand
this is comprehensible input showing
stuff but we're able to even show verbs
you know by doing this or a walking or
obviously you can't represent everything
you can't represent the style to how do
you represent that that's difficult but
the basics you can't so I don't think
it's necessarily true that you don't
understand anything if you have input
you do so you believe in this well I
actually I live you can speak without
having much input to tell me you know
the way I see is that for me the purpose
of having a conversation isn't to
impress the other person it's not so
they'll think wow he's like a native
speaker
is to actually accomplish a
conversational goal to be understood
people have lost this have lost sight of
lost side of this speaking language
communication is for communication and
so what I would say I saw a video just
last night where someone said I don't
want to have a conversation until I can
discuss politics world affairs and
history now that's great it's a fine
girl but 9019 the conversations I have
in the real world are not on politics
and philosophy it's things like oh my
foots hurting do you have some cream
please to make the pain go away all
right well I like the dog women say how
old is your dog is that he's ever so
cute you know these are not complex
topics so practicing language in in we
you talk about language partner but even
in real life you can just have simple
conversations like how much is the bus
ticket these kind of real-life
conversations will build your confidence
yes Anthony thanks so much you see my
pleasure wise take care for program hugs
a lot of hugs from frog chow